See you soon
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my video all about the Loki episode 6 ending.
Some of the stuff that it sets up, Doctor
Strange 2 multiverse of madness Ant-Man 3
quantumania Spider-Man no way home.
And a lot of the other bigger stuff like marvel's
what if series, which now makes a lot more sense
how crazy it's getting with the multiverse.
I will be doing full episode videos for marvel's
what if.
It starts in a couple weeks so be sure to
subscribe to get all those videos if you're
brand-new to my channel and careful for spoilers
from everything that happened on Loki if you
haven't seen the finale yet.
Because we'll be talking about everything.
And thankfully a lot of the producers the
writers have come out since the episode is
aired in clarified some of the details in
the way that they use big characters like
Kang for instance like the prime Nathaniel
Richards the original who found Alioth in
then one out in the battle of supremacy of
timelines, but in effect what they do here
at the end of the episode creates the other
comic book versions of Kang the will see in
the upcoming marvel movies so I will explain
that and I will explain the time loops because
I don't got really confusing with the way
he talks about seeing Sylvie again.
Like what does that mean yes, everything did
kind of get rebooted.
But when Loki does go back to the TVA, it's
a slightly different version the TVA implying
that a different Kang eventually won the next
multiverse war.
Like the multiverse war 2.0 that they were
teasing, but will explain the new timeline
and why Loki seeing it this way here, but
why it's going to play out a little bit differently
during the new marvel movies that were going
to be watching the next couple of years thinking
to show us the consequences of what just happened
with Sylvie just did in slightly different
ways in the different marvel projects are
coming up including marvel's what if episodes
big multiverse series with the watcher Doctor
strange to multiverse of madness.
Which is a little bit different Kang won't
be the main villain of that, but there will
be many Kang's from different alternate timelines
warring with each other from across all realities,
while that's going on.
So starting with the whole idea of the time
loop the time loop is important because Kang
need Sylvie to kill him, so that the timeline
will start again restart from zero so to speak.
And he can eventually become the person that
he is supposed to be that he's destined to
be a Nathaniel Richards or immortus that we
see before us he who remains, because the
multiversal war that he talked about that
happened in his past was responsible for turning
him into this person that we see before us
of the multiverse war has to happen for him
to become the final boss form version of himself
the most powerful version of himself that
winds up in the citadel at the end of time,
controlling everything, so he won't wind up
coming to power.
Unless Sylvie kills him.
And because this is all happening with Loki
and Sylvie traveling to the future to the
end of the timeline for them so to speak for
Ramona it as she hasn't happened yet in the
past a lot of the original multiverse war
hasn't happened for them yet, but they are
feeling the effects of it because of what
Kang did after he won the war in his past.
So if you've ever watched any the doctor who
episodes.
With different versions of the doctor showing
up at different points in his timeline he
sort of clarifies why the timeline works on
a loop in this 3D PowerPoint presentation
that he gives them.
It depicts the timeline is a circle around
him showing that it is a loop which you see
at the beginning of the episode depicted with
the curvature of the sacred timeline curving
around the citadel at the end of time.
Even though it kind of looks like the bifrost.
If you travel to the final point at the end
of the timeline and look forward you would
see the beginning of the timeline in the next
moment you just walk into moment zero like
.001 seconds right after the Big Bang, it
sounds like Kang did something after he won
the multiversal war to engineer it so that
it would do this that it would loop around
on itself by making the timeline a loop.
It also helps him maintain control of the
entire timeline from start to finish simultaneously
while he's sitting here at the end of time.
They also use this metaphor of the hourglass
turning upside down time resetting when Sylvie
kills them to with a lot of their camerawork
and with a lot of the hourglass imagery that
you see baked into the architecture of the
TVA, so for instance when Loki and Sylvie
are walking through the halls of the citadel
at the end of time before they me Kang the
turning of the camera like the rotating of
the camera here is meant to represent the
turning of an hourglass foreshadowing the
turning of the time loop thing starting over
again everything repeating in then eventually
what happens basically after this moment time
restarts the timeline proceeds like you would
normally expect you eventually get to the
31st century a version of Nathaniel Richards
discovers alternate timelines.
Like he said in his old PowerPoint presentation
in another multiverse war eventually breaks out again
But I'll talk about the twist at the end to
with the new King statue the idea that another
Kang one that multiverse war and is now controlling
the TVA doing things a little bit differently
from our Kang primer are Nathaniel Richards
prime he who remains that we saw notice that
you also see them walk into this room with
the statues with the broken one on the floor,
there's a circular pattern depicting the phases
of the moon like just sort of foreshadowing
the idea that it just all moves in a loop
and also clarifying what's going on with this
broken statue here, the four statue like there
was his whole lie about the three time keepers
why is there suddenly 1/4 time keeper here
inside the citadel of the end of time with
the story here.
I believe this fourth time keepers statue
is meant to be for a big deep cut from the
comics, the Oracle of see what within the
fantastic four comics, they canonize the Oracle
as the fourth time keeper who was sort of
written out of their history.
He was exiled by he who remains to ancient
Egypt and then wound up helping the fantastic
four during one of their adventures when they
were fighting another time travel villain
that wasn't Kang, but just to be clear the
way that Kang he who remains explains here
during the end of the episode.
The time keepers themselves don't actually
exist.
They were just a complete lie that he fabricated
and just hid behind use them as a proxy so
to speak to give orders to everyone at the
TVA as opposed to this version of Kang that
we see at the end of the episode.
Who seems like he didn't bother with that.
Like he just flat out told them I am Kang,
I control everything do what I say is a really
cool thing they revealed is how they sort
of foreshadow what's going to be happening
in the future marvel movies that will see
as we see this time more this multiverse war
play out so inside the citadel at the end
of time.
You pry notice that on this asteroid here
this rock to the citadel all of Kang's technology
his architecture you see all these gold veins
running through everything that's actually
called Kinsugi is a really cool Japanese art
style to thing in real life.
The phrase Kinsugi literally means golden
joinery is the practice of repairing something
with gold to make the new version even stronger
even better in the way they use it during
the episode is a metaphor for the broken timelines
the fractured reality that happened after
the first multiverse war and that will eventually
happen again to remember what Kang was explaining
the big war and he said Alioth was born because
of all the tears in reality there were caused
by the multiverse war the ideas their battle
fractured all of reality in their when Kang
won the war, when he won out and defeated
these other timelines.
These other versions of himself.
He had to prepare his timeline and turn it
into the sacred timeline of the sacred timeline
isn't just his original timeline is sort of
a repaired version of his sacred timeline
that he's also changed and altered to his
liking.
Remember how he tempted Loki and Sylvie I
can give you all these things the infinity gauntlet
I can make it so that you've always lived
together and nobody thinks it's weird that
your kind of with a version of yourself yet.
Imagine when Kang was preparing his timeline
Kinsugi style weaving everything together.
He also took bits from other timelines that
he thought were even better making his timeline
even stronger in this whole concept also foreshadows
with the future of the MCU is going to look like
So a lot of people like okay will they just
reboot of the timeline.
It kind of seems like in it seems like a new
version of Kang one out in this multiverse war
Like Loki is getting a spoiler for the ending
of the new multiverse war he jumps to the end
Whereas the other marvel characters in present
day watch it all play out lot of you asking
is this how they introduce a lot of the other
characters like Deadpool of the X-Men characters
that are going to survive the transition.
Even though most of them up.
Like a be recast and rebooted versions of
characters.
Is this how Spider-Man no way home explains
them crossing over with the Sony Spider-Man films
Is this how they get daredevil from the Netflix
marvel universe into the MCU.
And I do think that they will rely on some
of those trope snow will be the same for every
single character like some characters will
have always been around.
Like you just didn't notice them.
But some characters like Deadpool the weirder
characters will probably come from other alternate
timelines, other universes in.
Like doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
Antman three quantumania.
Those are prime opportunities for them to
so together to fix things after the defeat
all these versions of Kang to repair the timeline
with a couple minor changes like a couple
of things from alternate timelines wind up
getting incorporated into the new main MCU timeline
So if you understand what Kinsugi means and
how they're using it during the episode, you
kind of see they're foreshadowing this coming
like okay were going to be combining a bunch
of different things as we repair what's eventually
going to become the new main MCU timeline.
But that doesn't mean the going to use that
twist to say bring Robert Downey Jr Iron Man
back to life.
Kevin Feige did say that Doctor Strange 2
would introduce alternate versions of avengers
characters equipment you don't look like the
avengers that I'm known before another good
example that is the marvel what if series
is can have a very dark version of doctor
strange when all the timelines are branching
out going crazy during the episode yet.
Imagine that the what if episodes will be
taken from a lot of these different timelines
also for those of you asking about some of
the connections between Kang and Iron Man
some of the stuff that come before in the
MCU other fantastic four characters.
There were some deleted scenes that do help
sort of connect him to the other marvel characters
for instance also if you look at his wrist
device the tempad the uses the advanced tempad
that looks like it's made using that Kinsugi
art style with all the gold arcs running through it
The design language is based on iron man's
time travel wrist device, like it almost looks
like a more advanced version of that the whole
idea is that can come from the 31st century
though everything that he learns all of his
technology is based on what's come before,
so some saying, yes, there is a connection
between Kang in the present day Marvel characters.
Even though this is obviously a version this
millions of years old see a lot more those
connections with the younger versions of Kang
when they show up in all these other marvel
movies some of the more evil versions the
more benevolent versions the more Willy Wonka
looking versions a little bit manic and crazy.
This also a lot of biblical references going
on here too when they're talking to Kang this ending scene
He calls himself the devil, he's holding that
Apple when he meets them.
That's not a coincidence sort of like he's
tempting them with knowledge.
Like he is the snake in the garden of Eden
tempting Eve with knowledge which she bites
from she takes his bait this is the David
Fincher's seven movie kind of influence a
little bit of what's going on here to Kang
emotionally manipulating Sylvie into killing
him the same way the villain of the seven
movie manipulated Brad Pitt's character into
killing him at the end they also said that
they wanted this version of Kang he who remains
Kang to feel like a young tech CEO odd brash
as much of a genius as he comes up like a
charlatan like you don't know if he selling
you a lie or vaporware to make the tech CEO
metaphor is playing into the idea that they
can't completely trust him.
Like Loki kind of believes him Sylvie is ready
to believe anything that he says in the reason
why this and Sylvie has such a hard time with
this sort of clarifying what Sylvie and Loki's
conversation was all about where she said
I was prune before you were ever born what
she means is before Loki was born as a variant
not before he was literally born because they're
both about the same age and Loki in the MCU
it's a little over a thousand years old.
So she was prune when they were both children
then almost a thousand years goes by and Loki
becomes a variant.
So she is existed as a variant on the run
for almost a thousand years in our Loki has
only been a variant for a very very short.
The other clever thing they do in this end
credits scenes are like a post credits mid credit scene
There is kind of one it's a season two announcement
but what they're foreshadowing here not only
their making the announcement.
Like yes Loki is getting a season two.
That's going to be awesome, but there stamping
our Loki's file as if they're processing him again
Like it's this new version of Mobius from
this different version of the timelines that
didn't meet.
Loki originally who doesn't know who he is
though this can be a time jump we pick up
in season two episode one, it will immediately
start in this moment here they're also using
this to foreshadow some of the plot like Ono
here we go again if he didn't see the news
after the finale air THR was reporting the
Tom Hiddleston's Loki is supposed to now show
up during doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness.
So even though he does know little bit of
magic.
He does have that flaming ancestral blade
he's of greater value to characters like doctor
strange 2 or credibly powerful and understand
the multiverse and really deep way he can
tell Doctor strange what happened while this
is happening who's behind it all.
Like this version of Kang is fighting across
different timelines with versions of himself
the ideas that will help Doctor strange fix
everything if he has a better understanding
of what went wrong.
But just to be clear, Kang is not going to
be one of the main villains of doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness.
There were also a lot of deleted scenes from
the finale.
I will do a big deleted scenes video sometime
in the next day or two.
Because there's a lot of really cool stuff
they didn't do a lot of big Easter egg moments
a lot of alternate versions of the ending
for those of you asking what happened to King
Loki don't worry this actually good explainer
for what happened with all those scenes.
It is any other big questions that you do
have about what happened during the ending
and how the new timeline works.
Why everything is looping our futures confused
about anything in general just write those
blown the comments and I'll use those in my
future videos on name a new giveaway winner
when I post that next marvel video.
So what you wiat for everything
Click here for my full Loki episode 6 finale
video and click here for that Deadpool and
Korg marvel crossover trailer.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!